Matthews in Rochester Minnesota with a
question for last hey Matthew how are
you good yourself Dave how are you doing
better than I deserve how can we help
you oh yes so I just had a quick
question I've been trying to get my wife
on board for some time she's getting a
little bit closer but not fully
hundred-percent on board every time I do
a budget she's like you do the budget
we'll do it once a week
but when the time comes she just sort of
her body languages rolls her eyes and
she tells me that I talk about it too
much which I probably do that which I'm
trying to get less of but I'm not sure
where to go from there because we make
too much money and we work too hard and
that's what I feel like I feel like I'm
a little bit more passionate about it so
I'm not really sure of what to do so how
to pull her into the not only the budget
committee meeting where you're learning
to do that where you're laying out your
spending together but also some of your
goals right les yeah so and I'm guessing
that you are just hardwired to do this
more than she is would you say that's
true
that's very true yeah your personality's
of that and that's not unusual at all in
fact when you have two people that are
as gung-ho and hard wired as you and
they come together you get a whole
nother problem right do my pain in the
guy and the gas thing but in this
situation Matthew I love you a question
we hear a lot and one of the things that
I would suggest is to first of all just
make sure that she feels understood and
do this from a genuine place make sure
that she feels understood about what is
it that is boring whatever may be her
fear is and one of the best ways of
doing that is just to kind of dip down
into her life story on money in her home
growing up how was it handled and to
kind of understand that background can
give you some insight and some empathy
for her and then it sounds like you're
already aware of this but maybe taking
your foot off the gas pedal a little bit
so there's no guilt guilt is a terrible
motivator
mm-hmm and so if she's feeling like oh I
just
can never measure up to what he wants
and so why try that's that's not good
right and so those are things if you can
help her feel understood and genuinely
trying to get in there and really
understand ask questions you know in a
way that is is compassionate don't don't
interrogate her but in ways that she
feels like oh man he really wants to
understand me in this area you'd be
surprised at how she can come along and
then I also I'm just always amazed at
how when one person begins to make some
positive changes that the other spouse
admires like a mobile hanging from the
ceiling that person has to find the new
balance in things and comes on board to
do that as well but Dave you've heard
this question a million times what am i
leaving out what else is math you know I
think I think you you the answer is that
closer I think it should be answered
it's it's kind of like you know lose a
few battles on some of the little knits
see things some of the little Dave isms
or whatever that you've been pushing so
hard lose a few of those battles to win
the war the war is unity right a unity
will supersede you you know you're if
you maybe not intense enough on the debt
snowball well
the intensity will come through the
unity faster than it will be just trying
to doll her passion level up on this
issue
right right that's exactly right
anything that comes through like I said
earlier get to know her fears and get to
know her anxiety around that and she'll
be joining you soon